[موسيقى] يطلق عليه
اسم متغير مثير للاهتمام
من قبل منظمة الصحة العالمية، على سبيل المثال 5 هو
فرع آخر من فروع أوميكرون ويقف وراء
حوالي 17 حالة جديدة من حالات كوفيد-19 في
الولايات المتحدة، لذلك يبدو في الوقت الحالي أنه ربما يكون قد
زاد من قابلية الانتقال ولكن
لا يبدو أنه كذلك  تشكل تهديدًا
للصحة العامة أكثر من المتغيرات الأخرى حتى الآن، على سبيل المثال، تم
اكتشاف 5 في 51
دولة، وتضاعف تواجدها العالمي
خلال الشهر الماضي، حيث استحوذت الصين على الجزء
الأكبر (حوالي ثلث
الحالات المبلغ عنها)، تليها الولايات المتحدة وكوريا الجنوبية واليابان وكندا
وأستراليا.
تمت ترقية سنغافورة والمملكة المتحدة بنسبة 2% على سبيل المثال eg5
من متغير تحت المراقبة
لأن مسؤولي الصحة العالمية يعتقدون
أنه يجب تتبعه ودراسته بشكل أكبر، كما
يقول الدكتور ADI Shaw مع Mayo Clinic
حتى نتمكن من مراقبة البيانات
واتخاذ مزيد من التحديد فيما يتعلق  إذا
كان هذا أكثر خطورة أو يؤدي إلى المزيد من
العلاج في المستشفيات في الوقت الحالي، تشهد الولايات المتحدة
ارتفاعًا في حالات الإصابة بفيروس كورونا (كوفيد-19)
وزيارات غرف الطوارئ والاستشفاء
ولكن من غير الواضح أن هذه
السلالة المحددة هي التي تقود هذه
الزيادات، ويعتقد خبراء الصحة أن
الحرارة القياسية تدفع الناس إلى البقاء في منازلهم
والسفر في الصيف.  قد يساعد في دفع
الارتفاع ومن المتوقع تحديث معزز فيروس كورونا
بحلول الخريف، وذلك لأن
المعزز يستهدف xbb
وهو سلالة
عائلة Omicron التي يرتبط بها eg5 أو يأتي
منها، لذا من المحتمل أن يحمي
ضد eg5 أيضًا  دقيقة صحية
أنا آندي جيثر